hey everybody its Jessie and good
morning if you're in my timezone or near
there so this is a lot earlier than I
normally stream but we all get here at
the University we all get pretty much
everybody gets to go home at at noon
today because there's a big conference
going on and they need the parking
spaces for the people attending the
conference so we all have to leave
so still wanted to do a stream so we're
gonna do one it's gonna have to be a
short stream though because I I knew I
had a meeting at 11:30 but I had
completely forgot that there was also a
going-away party for somebody that works
here in the same building as I do at
11:00 so I'd like to I'd like to stop
into that cuz he's a really nice guy so
I like to be able to say goodbye to him
before before he leaves so I I was just
in the middle of reviewing pool requests
so kevin has submitted to pool requests
they both look really good i am i've
already merged one and i was just kind
of testing the the second one and this
is kevin AKA
kevie and 60 20 in the in the chat so
i'm not sure if he's in the chat or not
i expect this is going to be a smaller
audience since it's a totally different
time and I didn't even post it on on
Twitter or anything like til I don't
maybe a half hour ago probably not even
that long ago so hey everybody there are
a few people and the chat is picking up
a little bit okay so I'm just gonna
finish up just checking this out I'm
looking at it there's no you know don't
see any errors other than our normal
errors that we get so it's looking good
so basically what
what Kevin did was the first thing he
did was refactor the side nav so there's
nothing visible that happened but behind
the scenes there's a lot of code that it
was kind of removed moving around and so
it makes it a lot more a lot more
streamlined and now for the letterhead
he's made it so that it's basically let
me show you the code first I guess let
me get rid of this and open it up again
okay cool so we have the letterhead card
now and that's its component here so
basically he's before remember we had
just copied and pasted everything which
was okay just to see how the layout
looks but you don't want to leave it
like that so kevin was completely right
in refactoring this into its own
component and now let me go back to the
letterhead there we go so now you know
we just have you know the letterhead
here and it's since there's not a lot of
them it's okay like this and I probably
won't make it any smaller than this but
we probably could just loop over this
and we could take these props and put
them in an array and then we could just
loop over that array so we would just do
like a red dot map and put all the cards
you know in here like that
so that could be a further customization
that we could further optimization that
we could do but I don't know for is not
really a big deal to me if it were
closer to like 10 then yeah I'm
definitely making I'm gonna make an
array and look through it alright so
this looks good I'm just gonna check on
my other screen I have the I'll pull
this over in case you haven't seen it
before this shows this is the pull
request pull request 10 and this is just
showing the difference between it so the
letterhead card is entirely new so you
see this stuff on the left hand side is
how it was and then on the right hand
side this is how it is now after the
changes from the pull request so before
we didn't have it at all and now this is
in the air and this all looks good and
then letterhead has changed you can see
you know able to remove a lot of this
stuff because now it's in letterhead
card
also able to remove a lot of that into
that repetition of all that markup
replaced with letterhead called card so
that looks good I'm going to merge that
also let me let me paste in the address
for the end Rock server so I'm gonna
paste that into the live chat and let me
bring it over in case you can't see
what's in the live chat it's this
highlight highlighted bit right here if
you can see the site as as we're working
on it and inspect it with dev tools and
a lot nicer than having to wait for me
to click on something for you to check
it out also I do have the the stream
open on Instagram as well so let's get
started and okay I just checked the live
chat so Taylor asked just 31 persons
here yeah it's just because it's in such
a different time than I normally do and
there I didn't give a lot of notice with
either the YouTube alert or with my
Twitter my tweet about it
alright Zanna Zanna has to go she's
going on a trip and she's got it for
Paris so thanks for checking in have a
great time on on your trip okay let's
get started so hopefully now if you want
to see this you've gotten that now we're
going to merge this in so I've actually
merged the master branch into this this
branch that I pulled on for testing
which is the pull request ten so I've
already merged into that just to test it
with everything and make sure it all
works properly and
I do want to double-check one more thing
before I merge this and that was the
side nav so I want to make sure
yeah I was afraid of this that this
might be the case let me jump back
mm-hmm okay on my other screen I'm
comparing that last I just wanted to
make sure that when I did the merge that
nothing got messed up with the last pull
request number nine that I had merged in
and so I just wanted to check what it
should have looked like so let me let me
look at this is sine MF yeah maybe this
just to say okay maybe it is all right I
thought I'd seen something that didn't
look right but right now that I'm
comparing it it looks looks about the
same as it should yeah okay cool
everything looks good
so I'm gonna check out master branch I'm
just gonna do like a basic merge I know
we had we tried out different ways to
merge things it in a previous stream
what's this letter I'm just gonna do a
really basic merge here and not go
through so there's a look basically the
reason I said that is there's a lot of
options for how you merge and what
happens when the merge goes in so you
know the most basic is just merge but
there's a lot of other things you can do
with that
all right also another thing that was
added in pull requests 10 from Kevin was
that the random images in fact they're
random you know for each each card now
which I mentioned yesterday uh I like
that and that's really cool also this is
fixed so before we had uneven spacing so
between the first two cards we had no
padding at all and we had a pretty good
amount here probably double with this is
and then no padding again so now that
that problem is fixed so looking good
let's move on now and we're gonna do is
share a story yeah this is where we left
off yesterday with shared story and I'll
bring up the mean Logan even show you oh
I also I forgot to tell you what what
happened so yesterday I left you all and
I had to go check out somebody's
computer so it turns out the problem so
basically the person could not access my
website he was saying that there was
just a blank screen and this has been
going on like for a long time and other
people
from the IT department had tried to
check it out and and couldn't figure out
what's going on so my suspicion was
correct I suspected that he was just
using an old browser and he was he was
trying to open it in Internet Explorer 9
and didn't realize it so you know the
user was you know basically not yeah
he's not really into computers so he
didn't realize what was happening but he
he assumed that it was opening the link
automatically in Chrome because that's
what he normally used but the default
browser on his machine was set to
Internet Explorer 9 so that there was a
lot of confusion I think from that
because he was you know saying and
thinking that it was in chrome where it
should have worked not realizing that it
was Internet Explorer 9 and some people
had checked out his computer before and
told him that his browsers were
up-to-date so he assumed they were
up-to-date as well so I don't know if
they just meant chrome is up-to-date and
didn't bother with Internet Explorer
because they didn't think anybody would
use it but in reality like Internet
Explorer 9 that's pretty old
I believe that came out in 2011 so
really old so anyway I was i I was a
little bit I'm relieved that it wasn't
my project it wasn't my fault but I feel
bad for this for this person because
there was important information that was
being conveyed through that that site
and he couldn't get it for months he
hasn't been able to get it and so I feel
really bad about it and he was
legitimately angry about the situation
and I can't blame him I just wish he
hadn't been angry at me since it wasn't
really my fault but the unreality based
on everything that he was saying and
been told it seemed like it was my it
was my issue so in fact he had actually
been told by other people that it was it
was on my end it's my excuse though
so anyway I can't be mad at him I was a
little bit upset about the whole
situation in general of like why are we
still have Internet Explorer 9 on
computers and here
so anyway but now I'm uh I'm over it I
was I was mad for a little bit but now
I'm cool so anyway just want to say that
because I know you all had some of you
had said at the end of yesterday's
stream that you wanted the update so
there's the update while Patrick says in
the live chat end of support for
Internet Explorer 9 was a year and a
half ago Wow Wow
I did forward on so I I wrote several
emails to various people about what
happened and I'm I'm trying to get the
browser's updated or like at the very
least I wouldn't care if they just
deleted Internet Explorer off
everybody's computers that would be fine
with me too because why would you need
everybody seems to have chrome on campus
anyway so anyway it's not really you
know my department's responsibility or
my call at all I don't actually have any
access to update anyone's browser even
even if I wanted to so I can't really
fix that but hopefully you know we'll be
able to get that fixed at some point
because this is not the only time that's
happened
some people somebody was using a really
old version of Safari once and that's
why my site didn't work
some people continually try to log in
with Firefox 3 from somewhere on campus
and I can't figure out who it is because
my my error tracking setup for that site
also tells me their email addresses but
the code can't even run the part where
it grabs their email address so it gets
held up even before that so I can get an
IP address but I don't I don't have any
ability to figure out whose IP that is
so anyway enough of that hopefully I
won't have to handle too many of those
situations again and oops
form we're gonna go to suggest a story
form okay so for this form we're just
gonna have some paragraphs and some form
elements we decided yesterday that we
were not gonna put this on a card we're
gonna try to put it you know directly
onto the paper and we're gonna make this
font a larger size and we'll see how
that looks so let me move this off to
the other screen and first thing first
things first let's just make a container
where we got the story I thought I named
it okay so let's copy some some some of
the mark-up over from let's see posters
letterhead would actually be good to
copy it from because we have some P tags
up at the top of the letterhead just
like we'll have with this okay so I'm
just gonna grab this whole container and
then we'll remove what we don't need
that this will save us a little bit of
time typing and now we don't need to see
that and we can get rid of this and I'm
just gonna leave these paragraphs here
because that's fine for now I don't I
know how paragraphs are gonna act what
I'm really worried about those I want to
make sure that we get the right font
size here so I am gonna pull in from
materialize the responsive font so I
let's see if we still have this open I
think we do yep so we still have our
materialized CSS file open from their
github repo so I'm gonna find the the
font so it's it's flow text it's not a
font this is just the
font-weight so you can see I'm sorry not
the phone what I guess it does set the
font way but the font size so you can
see a different screen sizes the font
size will change so there's a bunch of
media queries so obviously like I'm not
gonna spend my time rewriting all these
media queries right so we're just gonna
take this and put this in our CSS file
and I'm just gonna take this for now it
might be helpful to have some of these
other kind of helper classes at some
point but I'd rather bring in what I
need because sometimes at the end of the
project you never go back in and remove
all the stuff you don't need so I'm not
gonna copy everything in right now I'm
gonna try to be a little bit more
responsible about it I know the last
project there was a bit of a mess in the
CSS and I just ran out of time and
didn't get to clean it up so don't want
that to happen this time so I'm just
gonna put this in the do we want to do
this yeah this is I'm gonna put this in
a separate file for now I think I'd like
to keep my CSS in different files yeah
and then that'll help keep it a little
bit more clean so let's make another
file or another yes I already made this
aw I was thinking I'd make another
directory but I think I already made it
so I think we just need to touch source
styles yep that's it and we'll name this
all right and I'm naming it float X
because that's the name of the class so
I I'm immediately gonna know what that
is I guess if you haven't worked with
materialize you might not know what that
is but at least you'll know maybe I
should change it then because I do want
people you know down the road to be able
to look at this and see what's going on
so we'll call responsive responsive text
okay yeah that's a little bit more
descriptive of what it what it is
oops
and I almost misspelled this so I didn't
mean to say tough I wanted to say touch
so touch is how you create a file in the
command line okay now we can see that we
have this file if I open up a folder
here we should have that file what
happened to this
should be there right source styles oh I
just didn't see it how did I not see
that I think I was I was thinking that
it would have showed up green since I
just added it so that's why I didn't
even bother reading it which I don't
know why I didn't show up bringing
normally new brand new files do appear
as being green so not not really sure
what's going on with that but we can
finally copy this in and let's save that
and then we'll bring in I'm probably
gonna end up using this will it use this
everywhere actually I won't use this
everywhere so there are gonna be some
pages where I won't even need this
because we're gonna have we're not
really gonna have blocks of text so I
don't know that I need to pull this into
every page let me check oh I have it on
the other screen isolettes let's just
check quickly because I think we can try
to yeah I'm not I don't actually want it
on this page I want to keep control of
exactly what these sizes are on the home
page same thing with this page and this
page of text yeah
and yeah the the text inside of cards
I'd rather keep more control over the
size just because I do want to make sure
that we have cards that are the same
height and I don't want to be huge if I
applied the flow tech stuff in the cards
that they would be really big so
[Music]
yeah so some of the like these pages
obviously I could apply it to but yeah
so my whole point point is like I don't
want to have to load CSS in places where
I'm not going to use it so here's what
we're gonna do so we can see like on apt
ass we're importing our Styles up at the
top so I'm just gonna copy that and
paste it into story and change this to
responsive text okay now we should be
able to put I should be able to put flow
class or float X class here and it'll
just apply to all these paragraph tags
so let's see if that is the case
oh okay I see let me
oops you need to go out and back inside
let's try this
okay cool if you didn't catch that so
initially I just had one dot which would
have meant from where this is so from
the views folder it was trying to find
within the views folder a Styles folder
okay which obviously is not the case
okay so it worked when I had it like
that within App dodge' ass because app
Taj is is here within the source folder
so what I had to do was put another dot
and that's saying go up one level right
so go to the source folder then try to
look for the Styles folder so be aware
if you're moving components into other
other directories within your project
that you may have to change some of this
stuff depending on how how you've done
it how are your projects set up so at
some point we're gonna make a components
folder and move some things into there
and we'll have to take care of that when
we do that as well so all right but for
now it's just what we want so we have
this it actually ends it's pretty large
fonts you had a fonts pretty large now
this is larger blocks of text then that
will have so actually I think I'm going
to bring in the the real text because I
would like to see now that we have the
the flow text applied I want to see what
this would really look like so you can
see it's not nearly as much the second
one's going to be a bit longer
and
bring this in
okay so this is the actual text
something just looks weird to me about
this what what is wrong with this
I'm no does that look odd to anyone like
it it just doesn't look as nice as maybe
there's some conflicting styles between
material you I and this bed yeah maybe
that's it
oh maybe it's the font am i not all
right said saying the font family is
just saying serif which is not what I
want maybe that's what I wanted to be
rubato which I thought Roboto was the
default for for material UI
maybe I missed a step and I have to
actually pull in Roboto at some point
let's check let's check on that because
I'm not really gonna know if this looks
good and unless I see the font nice
check out usage
I'm not seen anything there
because there's no there's no search for
the site
I wonder if it's like that with
everything if I'm not getting family
okay so Roboto is it's here it's just
not being applied here for some reason
okay let me I'm about halfway through
the stream for today so I do want to go
to the live chat just just quickly and
see if there are any questions or you
know any new people to welcome before I
solve this this font problem
Oh Sean says connections really laggy so
yeah sorry about that
okay Patrick sing there's there's more
to flow text than what I'm copying so
let me check did I maybe I missed maybe
I missed some stuff here
I mean maybe I should pull in some of
the baseline font stuff
okay I'm not
maybe I'm missing it
yeah maybe I had thought that maybe the
base font is different so then all those
the flow tax classes and the media
queries would be slightly off from what
I'm used to
[Music]
bill says have you thought of using
styled components yes I have thought of
using the style components so I'm gonna
look into that I would actually like to
make each of the components completely
self-contained if I could so say that
could be a goal for this project because
then I'd like to be able to just reuse
them
it'd be cool actually to make like Kevin
had made the letterhead card it would be
cool to just make card component which I
mean they already have the card
component so I'd have to call it
something different it could be card but
basically a component that would be like
it would have the card there but you
could control everything in it just
through props and then that way I could
reuse that for all my projects just
control and what I mean by what's in it
like whether or not it has an image at
the top a title and overlay text action
buttons so all of that would be in props
and maybe I'm missing something and
that's how material UI is already set up
and trying to reinvent it here but I
think that would be really versatile and
especially since I use cards and pretty
much everything that I do that would be
a component that would be awesome that
make that completely self-contained with
everything that it needs to render and
just be able to drop it into any project
I just see Rowan asked about what the
issue was yesterday with the project and
I CEO told him that it was Internet
Explorer 9 yeah this is terrible
Blake asks what is docker docker is like
a weighted like like you make a
container and your program can run in
that container and you can transfer that
container so and I mean like everything
can run like your entire setup the whole
stack can be in this container and it
can be copied exactly on to anybody's
machine no matter what they're running
and it's supposed to be able to run in
exactly the same way and you don't even
have to install all the same stuff on
your machine but if you're running
something in node and you didn't have
node installed on your machine it
wouldn't matter if you had docker and
you downloaded the the container then
you should be able to run it so that's
my understanding of docker I haven't
used it in at least a year I would start
I wanted to use it more and I just got
busy with things and never felt
comfortable enough with it to use it for
you know in production
i Patrick had some and and Bill had some
good explanation as well for for docker
basically saying it's like like a
virtual machine yeah so said it's like
like a lightweight virtual machine
nice Emily arsenal of color aquatics
says come on guys thumbs up this yeah
cool give it a thumbs up if you want I
don't I mean it's cool when your thumbs
up that but I don't really know if
thumbs up mean it means much in terms of
of anything I don't really know how that
that helps other than letting me know
that you like the video though they
sebastian saying mature you i was
designed with Roboto font mine so be
sure to include it your project
where is that look over
okay Patrick said I did get all of the
flow tech stuff so cool so Sebastian I'm
let me go back so we're working on
trying to get Roboto to be the font for
for this which I'm it's already being
applied to like H tags and I'm not sure
why it's not being applied to these P
tags at least inspected again yeah so
you can see like on our P tags here it's
it's saying that our font is just saying
serif so I'm not exactly sure what the
problem is and why we're not getting you
know on the same page you know some
things have that fun some things don't
so I may just have to import the fonts
in one of my main CSS files actually
here's the thing I'm not sure about we
can test it out but if one of you knows
it'll save us a few minutes if I put in
different CSS files so it's obviously
any importing that font in photo Roboto
exists already somewhere material UI and
it's already being imported if I try to
import it again in another CSS file will
the browser know that and not bother
bringing it in again or will try to
bring it in twice that's that sounds
weak the only I mean possibly if if
there are different locations that it
was getting it from it might think it
was two different files but right it
shouldn't try to pull it in again
right so I know there's a delay so it'll
be a minute before you all hear that and
can answer so I guess in the meantime
just to prepare I can look up okay so
this font
[ __ ] what a thinner bottle a regular
medium bowl I don't know that I need all
of these whoops okay so
I rarely use bold or medium so I'm
definitely not gonna use bold it's
possible that if I want something to be
bolded I'll use medium so I will grab
that cuz not I think about it there's
might be some stuff that's boated and
then I do use I do like to use some of
the thinner stuff if I can on some
monitors though it's really hard to read
the thin stuff so it definitely has to
be a large font for thin to work so
let's bring that and let me check this
see this
okay Sebastian says it's inherited but
not using their about a font Roland says
it's from the same if it's from the same
source it's won't if it's different
location versions it will try okay
but since it's already imported you can
just use Roboto
actually I I want to see what's being
imported let's see what let's check it
out here see where it's coming from or
might be easier just to check here wow
that's a lot of stuff that when you
refresh this page I don't want to see
all this
okay you know what maybe I won't be able
to see it
okay
I do want to see though if I before I
pull in all the font stuff if I just go
into this responsive text new flow Tex
are we getting robot enough
here we go we've got Roboto now okay
cool
so anyway thanks you said that so I
think it was some of the Sebastian said
that made me want to do that instead so
thank you
oh yeah and Roland's mentioned since the
age tags are using it it's obviously
imported already so that should be
that'll work
I mean maybe maybe I could put in one of
the CSS files I'm not gonna worry about
it right now I just want to get this
page done but in one of the CSS files
maybe I will put just like globally like
everything gets Roboto one of the ones
that I import into the app.js file okay
cool so that's it now like I said I'm
still not sure I'm just not sure about
the size I mean maybe I maybe it just
looks weird because on my other screen
I'm looking at the really small size so
this is what I'm looking at and it's
like a huge difference so maybe that's
just the kind of the weirdness that I'm
but I'm getting here all right but I do
want to before we end today I want to
throw in some some fields some form
field so let's check out the fields
sexy oh so okay so which one there we go
I want the floating label that's what we
have now so I need two text fields and
then a multi-line with the floating
label okay so first things first let's
import text field
get that semicolon out of here I don't
care if you all use semicolons but I
just now that I'm not using them anymore
I can't stand them
let's see floating label there we go
let's pull that in we're gonna need to
make a little container for that so we
want that to be 50% with so we're gonna
get class and that's gonna be six okay
so with the : classes that we brought in
from materialize the materialized CSS
framework this means on small screens
it's going to take up 12 columns which
means full width and then on medium
sized screens it's only going to take up
6 so it's going to be 50% width and then
we're gonna put our text field in and we
need two of those so and put that there
and then we need a full width multi-line
text input
and yet we want the floating they were
one
so actually I want to try let's see
don't want to try this I want to try
this I'm just curious
oops now I meant to put another column
let's see how this turns out
that doesn't
at this I'm gonna get rid of the hint
text obviously I don't want the hint
text but why is this this big there must
be some sort of max max length set okay
so that does stack like we wanted to so
the thing I was saying I wanted to try
out is not to make another row and just
to put all these and my my reasoning was
if I put another row it's gonna add in a
margin and then it's gonna look Auton
small screens so there won't be a
uniform spacing between here so that's
why I did it like that and I because I
had noticed that that's how Kevin did it
when he refactored the letterhead page
all right so let's check this out to see
if it has a max width
or I guess just a width where is it
getting this width from okay so that's
saying a hundred percent so at some
point it's gotta be setting a width
I mean what'd you leave this over a bit
second you see
okay yeah this yeah that element with
here is controlling that so let me check
the docs see if I can just change it in
here because I I want it to be like here
I do have it full full width and that's
how I want it to be
fully there we go let's add four with
true
I wonder if I just add it if it'll if
it'll go true let's see I think it might
yet there you go so that's that's the
answer it we just have to add full width
which is awesome so full width now let's
check it out
awesome ok so we have our full width
going on okay not bad I think on the
other as it is now on the site it
definitely has a bit more padding but
I'm not I'm not super worried about it
okay cool so let's add in let's get rid
of the hint text and then we'll add in a
button and time is it and then we'll uh
then we'll wrap things up a hint text
there we go cool this is just I don't
know if you all can see this but it
looks like it's just not quite as smooth
like the animation for this bar it's not
quite as smooth as I have it actually
that's because on the only other thing
that's it so I'm not actually trying to
do like the the really cool animation
that they have here where it actually
expands and shrinks so that's that's why
there's I think I was just adding a
different color and and weight of border
okay cool let's find our buttons
amazing
raise fun yeah this is what I want so I
just wanted to say submit really to just
need a simple simple button that says
submit and we do want it to be the
primary color so let's import this
button and then we'll bring in this
raised primary put it
all right he's fun
so it's
style is not defined yeah okay what's we
missed something then style margin 12
all right I'm not gonna worry about that
right now let's just take out the style
and see how it looks and then we can put
our own margins in if we need to okay
cool so
actually
I'm gonna compare this okay so this is
my current effect I don't think they're
the same oops
okay I may change change how this is
working because I don't like it as much
as this
I'm gonna check I'm gonna have to check
the material design guidelines on this
just to see but I mean this is I didn't
build this a while ago but I'm assuming
that I followed what was with
materialized CSS for this effect and you
can see there they're definitely
different so in terms of I mean yes
there's a color change and then a slight
increase in the shadow to make it appear
like it's coming forward but you can see
like the increase in the shadow is
barely noticeable actually now that I
look at I'm not even sure that's
happening and I'm not sure yeah this is
happening faster it seems like there's
not there's not as much of a transition
okay so yeah I'll have to work on that
button because I just it's not as
satisfying hovering over that button as
this button I don't know maybe it's just
me but but realistically like if I need
if I want to keep a consistent brand
standard then we need to have the same
thing so I'm gonna need to change how
this button works then to be consistent
with what we're doing across all our
sites okay
so I think that's it so basically this
page is layouts done just need to change
change some text work on this button a
bit and that's pretty much it
I'll probably didn't do it like a
comparison to make sure that you know
these this font size is correct I just
wanna see what the base font size is for
material you either this is going off of
alright let me go to the live chat I'm
gonna go through quickly and hey one of
my co-workers is in Iceland right now
and she just was watching the live chat
and sent a message said hello from
Iceland glad you're working hard so I'm
not even seriously still watching enough
but that was cool
alright so I'm gonna scroll up I'll try
to get through everything but I do need
you know in a few minutes I'll need to
end the stream
hey we ended up getting about 50 we're
up to we're up to 49 viewers now so
that's not bad
I was I was a bit worried no one would
watch because it was at a different time
let me scroll down yeah if you have any
questions you throw them in a live chat
but I am I won't have a lot of time to
answer so if I can't get to him you just
send them to me on Twitter and I will
say I know that some of you have asked
me to look over your code and send me
messages and I've just been really busy
lately so hopefully I have some time
this weekend to check it out but just
please be a little bit patient with me
and I'll try I'll try to get to it
okay let's see
Rowen says it's too much text together
so yeah now that it's a bigger font it
does look like it's too much text so
yeah we'll see we'll see what to do that
I there's a good chance that some of the
the text will change when everybody you
know kind of reviews this again and so
we might be able to get rid of of some
of that text rohan says I'm partial to
semicolons just feels complete to me I
did it was weird not using semicolons at
first it felt the same way but now it's
you know it just looks nicer without
them
breath mesh as hey friends can I get a
job if I do full stack developing and
free code camp yeah I mean you you can
there there are people that have
definitely gotten jobs after doing free
code camp so it just kind of depends on
the quality of your work and you know
how many places you apply to what
they're looking for there's just so many
factors that go into actually getting a
job that I couldn't say for sure you're
gonna get a job with free code camp but
it's definitely gonna help you and help
you increase your skills and you know
the more skills you have the better your
portfolio is the better chance that you
do have of getting a job
Oh Sebastian I see you saw a full-width
before I did so thanks for that sorry I
didn't then look over and see that
now Patrick says why is the bottom field
so different than the other to look
where the blinking cursor ends up on the
bottom once it's active yeah it's
because it's a multi-line field that's
why so it's it's multi-line and it's
currently set to two two rows so if I
really wanted it to be uniform I guess I
could set it to one row and I'm assuming
it would expand actually now I want to I
want to make sure that it expands yeah
okay to expand yeah I don't I guess I
don't mind that I'm used to that but if
it'll look better we could always just
set it to initially just only in one
column I just want people to know that
they can type a lot in here if they need
to oh and I just see Patrick already got
his answer in their live shot so thanks
thanks Sebastian for forgiving that
answer nobody said today e-string barely
yeah I did I'm not gonna be in the
office later on when my normally
streamed so I had to do a an early
stream but it might not be bad maybe
some people who because of the time
difference and things couldn't see the
later stream maybe they can't see it so
so I guess that's you know that's kind
of cool and says would you recommend the
beta version of free code camp or the
other one and do you have any idea when
the beta version will be released I have
no idea when it'll be released
and I I have no recommendation when
we're another because I haven't gone
through the beta version yet so I
wouldn't I wouldn't feel comfortable
giving a recommendation I'll just say
you're gonna learn a lot no matter what
if if you're a little bit more
adventurous and want to are going to be
okay if like something's a little bit
buggy then I'd say go for the beta
version if you're the type of person
that gets really mad when something
doesn't work right then stick with the
regular version because you know
obviously it's a beta so there's gonna
be things that don't work right so
that's that's my my advice
some talk talk about my editor it is
Adam it is the SETI theme SETI yes it
does look similar to sublime Jay rec
says what age did you actually start
working as a dev okay let me let me
think I'm gonna have to do some math in
my head here I also say this I got paid
to build websites when I was I don't
know like 18 was probably the first time
I ever got paid to do a website
somewhere around there so but I
definitely didn't consider myself a
developer at that time so I would
probably say let me think how old am i
right now 30
I think I'm 31 right I'm 31 maybe around
28 I'd say I probably wouldn't really
consider myself a dev until I was around
28 and at that point I was freelancing I
think I was freelancing for a little
while before that but it was mostly like
stuff you wouldn't really consider being
a dad like I don't like customizing
WordPress themes like basic CSS
customizations to a wordpress theme to
me I don't necessarily consider that
being deaf work I didn't consider dead
work when I did it before so so whenever
I was doing that I you know I I was
getting paid to do web site stuff but
real dead word probably I was maybe 28
somewhere around there give or take a
year so actually occasionally I see
people say something like I'm already 20
years old and I don't have a job and as
a developer and like they're freaking
out so don't worry about it don't worry
really so
yeah okay so DeMar DeMar key how I'm not
sure how to pronounce that pronounce
your name so let me know if I'm
pronouncing it wrong but De Marchi Allen
says I'm 23 with good practice could I
get where you are definitely definitely
for sure so when I was 23 I was I think
I might have been a waiter at the time
all right and then I taught high school
okay demarcus okay I was like thinking
it would be like the French
pronunciation but Demark is cool
sorry for mispronouncing it so yeah so
anyway though let me give you just a
brief timeline I actually did a video
explaining like my timeline on my own
channel so if you check out the link in
the description of my channel I did a
video on like how I became a friend of
dev that'll give you a better idea of
just like how long it took me to learn
things so but basically when I was
around let me think
so I graduated with a business degree in
2008 I couldn't find a job for like six
months I worked as a manager at a Burger
King and then I quit that job and I
worked as a waiter at a restaurant and
then I got offered a job as a high
school teacher so I took it because it
was in my hometown I really wanted to
move back so I took that job and I
taught I actually taught Latin and
religion at a high school for almost
four years then I quit that job and I
traded money on the stock market for a
little while until I ran out of money
and then so obviously I stopped doing
that and I looked for work for a couple
of months couldn't find anything and
then finally I've started doing website
stuff and for I say probably the first
year of doing that I would not have
considered myself a dev it was mostly
like search engine optimization work
writing blogs do making minor
CSS changes so I was definitely in my
late 20s before I really started to try
to learn how to be a dev so basically
within within the last like three years
maybe four years I've gotten to this
point because before that my knowledge
of development was really like basic
yeah no I didn't I did not have a formal
degree my degree is in business with a
specialization in banking finance and
economics not related to web development
although good to know
it's it's good to know how to handle
money and and run businesses and things
but yeah so basically my point is I
think you can definitely pick up web
development and really quickly get to
the point where you're good enough to
make that really nice site it's really
good thing so for me it actually took a
couple of years but I had kids and you
know at a family I was trying to make
money so I was taking a bunch of you
know I was taking work doing anything
like during that time of me learning I
was taking work you know doing
landscaping at people's houses painting
I'd like paint their basement I would
take work like that were just writing
writing blogs and things like that so I
was taking work doing anything I could
to provide for my family so I couldn't
dedicate all my time to learning so if
you did have time to dedicate to
learning you could probably learn way
faster and get better than me way faster
so don't don't be discouraged at your
current age it's just if you have the
the desire and the talent and and the
time to put into it you can definitely
learn this stuff I'm not saying it's
easy
takes work but you can you can learn it
alright so I'm gonna take maybe like two
more questions and then I'm gonna I'm
gonna wrap it up okay let's see I missed
this question so DeMarcus asked and do
you consider real dev work to be working
from scratch I wouldn't say from scratch
but the reason I say that about
WordPress is a lot of the customizations
you can do in WordPress come like just
through their admin interface so you
don't even interact at all with with
code necessarily so that's why I kind of
didn't really consider myself doing dev
work I would say you don't have to start
from scratch because really who starts
from scratch right even you know you set
up a project you install a bunch of node
modules and there's stuff in there that
you know there's already been thousands
of hours of work put into you know what
you're doing just from your build tools
alone so no one starts from scratch but
I think the ability to go in and build a
site using HTML CSS JavaScript actually
being able to write the code at that
point I would say that's your developer
if you can't do that then I don't know
that that I don't know that I would call
myself a developer I know people are
different definitions and but if I
wasn't able to go in and in a code
editor and put out a website you know
just with the you know basic markup then
I wouldn't be I wouldn't feel
comfortable calling myself a developer
so hopefully that helps I don't want to
offend anybody who who does WordPress
theme customization it's you can make a
lot of money in that and it's definitely
needed but that's just how I felt when I
was doing it
DeMarcus s what are your thoughts on
bootstrap yeah I think bootstraps great
I think that's a great way it takes care
of a lot of really basic stuff in CSS
that in my opinion is a waste of time to
do yourself I mean it may be like once
just to see how it is and I'm thinking
mainly like like a grid system you know
all the different kind of things you
need to make things work properly across
browsers so things like that like nobody
codes that by hand so that's really
really useful so I think bootstrap is
good to know there's a lot of places use
bootstrap as well Jay says what
resources are using to learn this stuff
yeah free code camp YouTube videos
courses on Udacity all right DeMarcus
said great advice Jesse just subject
channel so thanks Hank I'm glad you like
the advice and thanks for subscribing to
my channel as well yeah I hope that
helps I thought I saw one more question
that I missed but now I can't find it so
sorry I okay here it is it was a
question about angular four are you
gonna cover anything like this for
angular for I don't have any plans to
cover angular right now I'm not ruling
it out for the future but I have no
plans at this point to do anything with
angular so yeah thanks for watching
everyone and I'll see you on Monday and
it was great thanks for adapting to the
difference in time I appreciate your
being so flexible and yeah
so have a great weekend